head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts ladies and gentlemen we have
tremendous news you want to you want to
read this one Luke oh goodness this one
triggered me a little bit this one's
from Fox Business Southwest Airlines
celebrated for policy to give a full row
to passengers of side
for free I am I am fat and uh from now
on anytime I fly I am morbidly obese or
identifying as moreb always uh this new
policy is apparently like Luke was
saying before the show like you walk up
to the counter and you say I'm fat so
give me free seats and they will yes ex
exactly did they weigh you beforehand
there's they I don't think they can I
think they'd be illegal I mean
I you God forbid your bag is 5 lbs
overweight right this is the argument
I've been making for a very long time
cuz I've been flying uh especially all
over Europe all over the world but in
Europe they nickel and dime you any way
they can especially when it comes to
Bringing on even just the carryon which
they charge you up to Wazoo and I
remember my luggage was like uh a couple
kilos over and I'm like look how skinny
I am look at those guys over there
they're morbidly obese why are they not
paying more why am I paying more for for
my bag that here's what we should do we
should get like an inflatable suit and
then you walk up to the counter you go I
need extra seats when they give you the
ticket then you you poke the thing and
then you shrink down and be like thanks
for the extra seats just see what they
would do why is it a whole row Is that
real though they're really going to give
the whole row there's people doing this
there's a video of a woman with a mask
not surprisingly probably we can't say
it here that that you know got on to the
to the thing videotaped herself doing it
and and literally came up and said hey I
need an extra seat and people like all
right I mean not to disparage overweight
people but it is sometimes like to incon
to sit next to somebody that's kind of
taking a part of your seat like i' I've
had that experience the Americans are
getting bigger the seats and in the
airlines are getting smaller uh and and
horrible you guys ready for this
one hi it's okay um I'm hoping to use
your um customer of size policy
today customer of size yes I'm leaving
yes thank
you okay thank you so much for your
help she got two have a seat Bel
extender please and a seat belt extender
thank you very
much thank
you what she doesn't even need it so uh
I I I'm I don't believe they could deny
you if you ask for this so ladies and
Gentlemen please get the word out if any
of you are flying Southwest at any point
before boarding ask to use their
customer of size policy that's it and I
don't care me personally if they're
going to be like sir you'll sit in the
chair just fine I'll be like excuse me
I'm
overweight what's the weight limit you
going to weigh me next what I'll take a
free seat I know so it could be
subjective I guess like who's overweight
and who isn't and like what's your like
you know body mass index ex yeah mass
and weight are not the same thing you
can be muscular and weight 270 lb and
just have like and this is a full flight
this was a full flight so they had to
kick someone off kick someone off
probably they kick people off uh out of
uh out of airplanes all the time well uh
you know I just got to let you guys know
you know I skateboard a lot and for this
I have uh uh large leg muscles which
puts my my my body mass index has always
been slightly higher for this reason and
uh well that means uh you know they have
to give me a free seat you're a big dude
I get a free seat your arms are pretty
big too look at that yeah you know very
strong impressive you're going to need M
I'm kind of mixed to of size well you
know some they I wonder if they have a
definition posted online or like weight
requirements like it's a what boxing
weight a lot of people got a lot of junk
in the you know why they you know why
they did this though it's not just about
giving customers of size the option it's
that they know like when Sydney Watson
was sitting sitting between the two big
people and the I'm sorry the customers
of size she posted on it on social media
like this is messed up right so South
West was like listen it's win-win if if
a customer is sitting next to them
they're both complaining right so just
give them a free seat yeah if there's
free seats on the plane I think but I
wouldn't like kick someone off a flight
for that that's crazy yeah but but like
do you want to cuddle with some like fat
morbidly obese person that's shedding
Spike proteins onto you and and sweating
on you and you got to smell their stank
for a couple hours no no I don't uh you
know what's really
funny when you fly private like it's
it's much more difficult for morbidly
obese people to fly private cuz they
have weight restrictions and there's no
sorry have a nice day there's no
questions this says the policy allows
larger Travelers the opportunity to
purchase an additional seat is that are
we missing something in the story is it
actually cost money no the the story is
that it's complimentary uh on Southwest
yeah on
Southwest but um yeah says free I guess
that's happy news for a lot of people in
America I'm being serious I know a lot
of people that will take advantage of
that yeah I mean do you do you want to
cuddle you know with someone with a lot
of junk in their trunk for a couple
hours it's always like for me I'd rather
sit next to someone who was not you know
I but more Americans are more than ever
obesity rates are going through the roof
heart rate disease rates are going
through the roof there's there's a
serious issue with seed oils and other
things that are absolutely atrocious
this is this is people are saying the
airline's bad here the FDA is bad here
our food industry is bad here big Pharma
is bad here those are the people that we
should be focusing on as of course they
fail us every step of the way ensuring
that we're going to be fat and sick look
fox says Southwest provided its policy
to Fox Business
which said that passengers of size have
the option of purchasing just one seat
and then discussing your seating needs
with the customer service agent at the
departure gate if it's determined that a
second or third seat is needed you'll be
accommodated with a complimentary
additional seat second or third that's
why I'm saying like get wear a fat suit
it's almost like enabling bad behavior
like en absolutely enabling like obesity
diabetes and everything else remember
remember on The Simpsons when Homer
realized that if you weighed over 300
PBS you can work from home
right so he tries to gain as much weight
as possible so he can work for home it
was almost like during Co when people
were you know at risk it was almost like
a good thing that they were at risk I
have diabetes or you know I'm morbidly
obese because that means I'm at risk and
I could stay home and I don't have to
come in yeah there there are definitely
times when you want to cater to the
weakest among you that just for the sake
of the tribe like keep them alive maybe
for a reason but then there are other
times when a society begins to cater to
like like if we if we have to kneecap
our entire Society in order to
accommodate people that have let their
bodies become obese that's going to be a
very challenging thing to subsist like I
don't know if we can sustain that kind
of pattern because if they keep if it
keeps propagating more and more you know
negative entropy or or whatever you want
to call it negative outcomes then it's
just this is this is going to capitalism
is supposed to counter this we we've got
uh some of the timcast crew flying to
amfest on Southwest uh I think they
should absolutely demand to use the uh
customer of size policy it says here
that the uh it's at the discretion of
the Southwest employees and you may have
to advocate for your extra seat just so
you're aware absolutely and I think I
think you should and you should argue
that you have restless arm syndrome and
I I would say this oh yes I have an I
have I have an AR arm tense tensity
thing my arms go out and you know causes
me pain if I can't stretch my arms out
it's I'm sorry it's just it is and if
they say no be like so the only criteria
is that you're obese other there there
was a viral photo remember this where
the guy had a had a belt STP St to his
legs and then some woman was like a man
spreader in recovery and other people
were like it's a guy with Tourette
Syndrome trying not to kick you like
that's so messed up that you would
insult them like that I did that in an
airplane I I put my I put something
around my knees cuz I fell asleep and I
didn't want to knee the girl next to I
mean what what if you like hold on what
if you said um you know uh flight gate
lady I have very large testicles and I
need to keep I need to keep my legs
spread open the length of three seats
we're all going to be better off trust
me yes somebody has to wear a body
camera and just pull all these things
and see what passes technically men
should have bigger seats okay we got a
we got a manspread you know we got to
let the the we got to let the boys
breathe for our our masculinity I loved
that season of the culture War the
manspreading one where it was like a
whole bunch of guys were like the why do
why do all these men manspread and it's
like you're saying a lot about your junk
right now like there are a lot of guys
that are just like I keep my legs spread
because I kind of have to and then there
other guys be like I don't I'm like okay
I kind of get what you're saying with
that but all right yeah you got to cool
your junk uh this is what Southwest is
doing with this particular Airline fat
policy is just a few steps away from a
Wall-E prophecy where people are going
to be given scooters to ride around
everywhere because they're too fat and
can't move around anywhere this is this
is this is where we are headed to as a
society with the Obesity rates this is
where we are headed not that far away
from where Wall-E was and uh soon
Wally's going to be a documentary I want
to ride around on those things I don't I
just want to be rewarded for not you
know for taking care of my body I want
to I was actually a trainer on The
Biggest Loser what was it like and you
know so G it gives me a lot of empathy
toward overweight people and I have a I
come from a family I'm half Italian half
Chinese my Italian side there's a lot of
more really obese people on it so thank
God I have my Chinese side to balance it
out but um it's just I feel like you
know how was Biggest Loser it was it was
great working with people but they have
like decades obviously and Decades of
History uh mental history and it's very
hard to lose weight once you get to a
certain age especially like I'd say 50
like you have Decades of trauma of being
an overweight person but I feel like the
country enables it you know and not just
with uh with stuff like this but with
all this processed stuff they put in the
food a lot of that stuff is really what
causes weight weight gain all these fake
sweeteners like uh the corn syrup and
everything I think it's actually really
easy to lose
weight I I think fasting is huge for me
it is and I'm I'm lucky to say that I've
worked with people who are 500 lb and
well yes you're right that actually is
true it is very easy to lose weight it's
very easy for them to gain it right back
and and that's the issue so what we're
really talking about is yes I understand
there's glandular issues I understand
some people have it's mental 100% mental
but yo if you're just eating Lean Like
if you're eating I wouldn't even say
lean meat have yourself some fatty steak
and some greens and vegetables we go out
to eat I get a Caesar sale with no
croutons and I get a fon with extra
butter SCH slopped on Top butter all
over that steak Yeah I I keep telling
Tim don't do the greens the greens are a
scam oysters meat some fruit but that's
just my diet well you guys are very
lucky because that that's you know for
most people like a Frank footer is
protein you know what I mean like that's
like in this in the country especially
with the economy I agree I agree that's
what they think protein is well people
people what what Norman Boro I think is
going to will go down in history okay
well he probably won't uh uh but I think
he should go down in history as a as a
as a well-to-do but bad person Norman
borlock famously increased the crop
yield of I think it was probably wheat
you can fact check me on this one and
and it it what what he did was he's like
now we can produce more wheat and feed
more people the only problem nutrition
density doesn't change so the starch
content increases the nutrition content
decreases what happens now is poor
people need to eat something like four
or five times the amount of food to get
the same nutrient level so if you're not
getting enough selenium or zinc or
whatever in your system you're just
slamming boxes of craft macaroni and
cheese cuz your body's desperate to find
it you're getting fatter and fatter and
fatter thanks for watching this clip
from from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
Tim cast.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time